while we continue to watch hurricane
Irma's approach to the u.s. hurricane
Jose is swirling in the Atlantic Jose is
a category 4 storm threatening some of
the islands in the Caribbean left
devastated by
just days ago right now we're joined by
phone by Tiffany bender an American who
is stranded on st. Maarten after
Hurricane Irma destroyed nearly all of
the structures on that island Tiffany
good morning good morning guys
can you just give us a sense of what
you've been through over the past few
days I can try about 90% of the country
has been leveled we have been just most
like me and my three best friends have
just been wandering around trying to
find the safest shelter as we prepare
for Jose we were told by the embassy to
go to one of two hotels one of those
hotels have has been completely leveled
the other we stayed in during our MA
lost all of its windows but we did find
shelter in the staircase and it did
maintain structure was another part
unfortunately we couldn't stay there too
long a fear of the bacteria and mold
that was growing all throughout the
hotel
obviously the wedding and also we have
been warned of looters coming in and
assaulting hotel guests so we didn't
need to make our way to the American
University so are you secure there
toughening at Tiffany at this point yes
we are but we are unsure of how long
they are currently evacuating students
with no plans of evacuating the
remaining Americans there here there are
about 15 of us Tiffany what about any
provisions you may have food and water
there we all have a sufficient amount of
water there are some snacks here that
will probably be less by the students I
can imagine but again our chief concern
right now is our safety as leaders we've
been told on the French side broken
through the colonisation it's all guns
and Becks Tiffany we certainly hope you
stay safe there and get word soon on
when you can return home Tiffany bender
in st. Maarten Thank You Tiffany thank
you guys
good luck Tiffany Lonnie what is what is
she about to encounter here you saw
those pictures yeah with all the rubble
and all the debris scattered about the
island has been destroyed all right and
now you're going to put a category 4
hurricane in it
vicinity does it take a direct hit it
doesn't make a difference the most
dangerous part of a hurricane we know is
the storm surge the second most
dangerous part of a hurricane is flying
debris
there is nothing guys but flying debris
all over that island and there's no
place to take shelter from it because so
many the buildings are either
uninhabitable or they're gone entirely
as we heard from Tiffany there's really
no place for her to go no and concerns
obviously about her personal safety as
well during all of that it was Gary